und wir müssen staaten mit einem
tragischen unfall ein tödlicher crash
mit einem selbst fahrenden auto auf der
schwäbischen alb bei römerstein dass es
bei reutlingen da ist ein solch selbst
fahrendes auto in den gegenverkehr
gerast und hat einen riesigen einen
verheerenden crash ausgelöst
bilanz ein toter das ist ein apotheken
fahrer der das auto voller medikamente
hatte er noch am unfallort gestorben und
10 zehn weitere menschen sind verletzt
worden fünf davon schwer ein tödlicher
ein verheerender crash ausgelöst eben
durch ein auto das selbst fahren kann
ein bmw x5 elektrisch ein auto dass kein
fahrer braucht das autonom fahren kann
also komplett auf autopilot es soll bei
diesem crash auf einer testfahrt gewesen
sein und auf dieser testfahrt offenbar
auf autopilot stirbt dann ein mensch
zehn weitere details schon ganz richtig
gesagt hat werden verletzt unser bild
reporter thomas heckmann ist am ort
dieses tödlichen unfall drummers thomas
schiller uns die szene zeigt uns das
szenario wo das passiert ist und wie es
passiert ist ja wir stehen hier genau an
dieser unfallstelle
hinter mir sieht man ja diese 70
schilder hier beginnt die prof und in
dieser richtung also in richtung der
beschilderung nur dieses auto wohl und
hier beginnt wenn ich etwas auf die
seite gehe dann sieht man dass eine ein
kurvenbereich eine scharfe s prof und
deswegen auch diese 70 beschränkungen
was hier in der ersten kurve schon
passiert ist das ist ja scheinbar
unbeschreiblich dass also dieses auto in
die gegenfahrbahn gekommen ist mehrere
autos gestreift hat um dann frontal in
diesem video rein zu fahren auf dem dann
wohl dem ein personen ihr leben verlor
ja also vier autos insgesamt beteiligt
und eben unfallverursacher das sagt die
polizei ja bereits ganz klar offenbar
eben dieses selbst fahrende auto
richtig und das ist genau das was jetzt
geklärt werden muss deswegen ist auch
ein gutachter eingeschaltet ja auch an
der unfallstelle war um herauszufinden
für dieses auto zum unfallzeitpunkt
autonom oder war es von hand gesteuert
worden was ist da eigentlich passiert
und da sind ja genau diese fragen
vielleicht auch die sorgen jemand hat
wenn jetzt vermehrt autonom fahrende
autos unterwegs sind oder auch nur
assistenzsysteme jeden fahrer vielleicht
auch manchmal etwas unaufmerksam werden
lassen thomas jetzt ist die frage nach
einem schuldigen immer keine schöne
dennoch muss ja jemand dafür
verantwortlich gemacht werden und es
muss jemand gefunden werden warum dieser
tragische unfall passiert ist sollte das
auto autonomen gefahren sei zum
zeitpunkt des unfalls wer wer dank
schuld ja das ist die spannende frage es
gibt ja bei diesem auto losfahren ehre
stufen des autonomen fahren und da gab
es gerade auch anfang des jahres
tatsächlich
gesetzesvorhaben gesetzesinitiativen wie
man damit umgehen kann und dann kommen
die zulassungen vom kraftfahrtbundesamt
und alles dazu das ist also ein
ungeheuer spannendes auch dann weißt du
noch ungeklärtes thema was da wirklich
der ursache ist bei so einem unfall aber
wir dürfen nie vergessen selbst wenn uns
unsere autos fährt wir müssen ja auch
unsere eigene gesundheit schützen und im
notfall muss sich dann halt auch
eingreifen und darf mich nicht nur auf
der elektronik verlassen danke an den
unfallort zu unserem bild reporter
thomas heckmann dramatischer unfall ein
verheerender unfall mit einem
testfahrzeug einem selbst fahrenden auto
und die schwierige frage die uns hier
heute bei bild live umtreibt wer ist
dann schuld an einem solchen crash bei
dem offenbar auf autopilot geschaltet
war
[Musik]